fans of The Big Bang Theory can point
out plenty of fun moments from the
show's 12 Seasons from that time Penny
played by Kaley Cuoco gives Jim Parsons
Sheldon The Ultimate Christmas gift to
the scene in which Penny solves String
Theory it's hard to get any consensus on
which of the CVS sitcom Seasons viewers
like the best although most seem to
prefer the first six seasons naturally
the actors all have their own favorite
moments and several of them come in the
season 4 episode called the agreement
dissection Parsons told TBS I loved the
structure of this episode the way I got
to sort of take part in two different
story lines girls night and the fight
over the roommate agreement at home it
was also a really fun episode with Maya
and Bialik and in a 2011 San Diego
Comic-Con panel in which the actors were
asked about their favorite moments from
season four Bialik joked that a kiss
between her character Amy and Penny was
hers I Kissed a Girl
what happened to you and then Bialik
said more seriously that the drunken
kiss between Amy and Sheldon was really
her favorite Coco also revealed her
favorite moment as being from that
episode since she had to convince an
actor to sexually harass her on screen
Cuoco explained that the scene was her
favorite moment of season four although
it was hard for her to pick just one she
said I guess it was where I had a lovely
man have to grab my ass in an episode
when we were dancing and he was a little
older man and he was so nervous and it
was so against everything he believed in
and I was like honey just grab it just
do it and he closed his eyes and just
went for it in the episode Sheldon
crashes a girls night after lawyer Priya
basically nullifies the roommate
agreement he has with Leonard when Amy
Penny and Bernadette discovered that
Sheldon can do the Cha-Cha Rumba and
Waltz they decide to take him to a place
they can Waltz at a dance hall an older
man asks Bernadette to dance when she
says no he asks Penny and she agrees as
he takes her out to the floor however
the man takes a certain Liberty until
Penny slides his hand back into place
the man in question is Gabriel Sai an
actor who has just a few credits to his
name in fact his part in the agreement
dissection is so small that it isn't one
of them wherever he is now though he can
say his tiny little role had an outsize
effect on a favorite episode of The Big
Bang Theory Kaley Cuoco was happy to let
an older man squeeze her butt for the
aforementioned scene that said while she
was clearly committed to the part she
made sure that Penny was presented as
more than an object for people Desires
in the later seasons of The Big Bang
Theory in an interview with W magazine
Cuoco said that she was happy for her
character to be sexualized during the
earlier seasons of the sitcom at the
time it made sense as Leonard and his
friends were crushing on her she said it
was the cute girl next door to the Nerds
right that was all about booty shorts
and Juicy Couture zip UPS however both
Penny and kuoko grew up as time went on
and Cuoco wanted the character to be
shown in a different light to reflect
that especially when it came to her
outfits the son it's like can I have
like a long sleeve shirt how about a
slack how about a loafer I never want to
see that high heel ever again
[Music]
thank you